Film Courage: In what ways can a writer improve their
dialogue? Daniel Calvisi:  Listening practice, I mean just
keep writing keep rewriting have actors
read it out loud I mean they don't have
to be professional actors but just you
and a friend read it out loud listen to
how it flows I think that can be really
helpful
I like that listening where are we
listening listening to how people talk
listening to interesting people around
how they talk and then once you write
your dialogue read it out loud you know
do a table read with friends or your
writers group or just even if you read
it out loud yourself find it interesting
that a lot of times people certain
people end their sentences with right or
you know like and they they continually
do that is that important because even
though that's not you know if you can
get actually irritating after a while
but there's certain people that that's
how they sort of they always want
validation for what they're saying so
it's right right and women do that a lot
and I must say that about my own gender
so we do a lot of right right because we
want people to know that they hurt us
and they got what we said do we infuse
things like that into a script or is
that become too repetitive well you want
each character to sound unique to
themselves you know ideally if you
covered up the character's name and read
the line you would be able to tell that
it was that specific character because
they should have a specific voice and
yeah if you have a character who needs
validation and every sentence you know
ends with right or is that okay or good
then you would write that you know but
in listening to how real people talk it
doesn't mean you're transcribing it
exactly you know people don't talk like
they're in a movie but so there is a
certain amount of you know dramatic
license that you have to use but you can
write to cinematically you know you can
write to theatrically
into too much like your characters are
on stage and that can come through on
the page and that can really hurt your
script
can you give me an example of that I
find that interesting cuz I've
definitely seen that in films where it
doesn't feel real good well I would say
to writers that do that a lot would be
Aaron Sorkin and David Mamet but that's
their style and they've been around for
years and they can get away with it you
know and they write produce movies so
when we go see an Aaron Sorkin or David
Mamet film we know that that's the style
of dialogue that they're going to employ
it's gonna be a little bit more poetic a
little bit more about speeches a little
bit more you know stage ii but we know
that about their style any writers that
have impeccable dialogue where you you
just feel like they're real people and
you're in a restaurant overhearing
someone in another table have an
interesting conversation that's a good
question
i like i like paul thomas anderson any
of the any of the Best Screenplay
winners of recent years you know they
all have really great scripts I would
say Diablo Cody sometimes can get a
little bit too too stylized or stagey
but in general I think she has a really
good really good voice for her
characters are very distinct and it's
just important to find an interesting
way to express an idea even if it's a
simple idea an example that would be in
pulp fiction there's a moment where
Bruce Willis character goes to buy some
cigarettes and he says to the bartender
he says one pack of red apples and the
bartender says filters and he says none
and that's just a really cool fast
interesting exchange there as opposed to
five lines to explain what brand of
cigarettes he wants and oh you know what
how about no filters in those cigarettes
you know because it's very Norrish feel
it's very you know clipped and dark and
tight and it's just filters none
and that just gets the the idea across
you